so my name is Adam strabinsky I'm a
symbolic algorithm developer at Wolfram
research i'll be presenting and talk
about symbolic computing with geometric
regions it's a joint work with my son
tavo but he has classes so he couldn't
present the talk so i will present you
the talk so let's see we have many
regions many region types in Mathematica
so the basic categories are special or
basic regions formula regions derived
regions and mesh regions and the region
type I will be concentrating on in this
part of my talk is basic regions so what
are basic regions so basic visions are
some named geometric object is large
enough where should I make it larger ok
so here they are so regions are some
name geometric regions that that we have
built in there are commonly used like so
we have 36 of them right now there are
36 special region types and in version
10.3 we introduced 10 new special
regions types here are the released it
roger has already shown them so we'll
just scroll through to all the region
types to basic idea is that we have many
many of those
and so how do we do symbolic computation
with with regions so what do we want to
compute we can put compute region
properties so here are the functions
that compute properties member region
membership than the dementia properties
measure properties distance properties
and deciding whether region is bounded
and computing region bounds so here are
the prop various properties of regions
that we might want to compute we can use
region as input to symbolic computation
functions so here the functions that
take regions as an input so the solve
equation solvers optimization functions
integrations the assumption mechanism
all can take regions as input now so
what's what's the general method so that
is the most general method of handling a
problem involving a region is to find a
system of equations and inequalities
that describes the region and then use
the symbolic computation methods dude
let's solve the problem written in terms
of equations inequality so it will be
solving equations inequalities
quantifier elimination or constraint
optimization so and the most general
method that we use there is the cindy
college break decomposition algorithm so
in principle we can we can compute
anything about semi algebraic regions
these regions that are can be described
by polynomial equations and inequalities
but the algorithm we are using there is
general bite but it's slow and also in
general if we have derived regions like
region Union region intersection
transformed region those
auto simplify in general we can we
cannot do anything with you know we
can't represent arbitrary transformed
ree-ree transformation of an arbitrary
Genesis as a bill tree in region however
if we have special regions that that's
that's that's a different case we may be
able to represent derived region in
terms of of another special region so
here for basic regions if we if we are
thinking just just about the 36 special
region types that we have we often have
closed-form formula for computing regent
properties or for integration over the
region or we can auto simplify regions
constructed with basic regions and those
those formulas usually much using the
formulas or special methods is usually
much faster than using the general
method so for instance here's here's the
simple very simple example so we have we
have a ball let's describe using
equations inequality so if we write this
as any piece each region that's that's
what will happen here we are using the
trinity college by composition to
decompose the ball into into cylindrical
pieces and then we use integration to
compute the volume and in almost ten
seconds we have we have the volume of
the three-dimensional ball but of course
if if you just request volume of
three-dimensional then you get it
immediately this this time here is
loading the package we do second time
around it probably will be zero well not
I don't think we have we can you make it
work with symbolic and what you can do
90 volume volume is a 3d volume
so it's infinite 49 dimensional board
for regional measure is zero time and we
got the answer because we have the
formula for n dimensional for volume of
or measure of n dimensional ball so
that's that's what of course if I tried
integration that that would probably
take a very long time okay we have
that's why we got the result so how is
the implementation of specialized method
how is it done so basically we we have
collection of formulas or specialized
algorithms for computing with basic
regions we can compute properties of
special regions operations or by on
basic regions and relations between
basic regions so what what are the
properties so here is rather long list
we have 20 properties of basic regions
and 12 properties of basic region
boundaries because a boundary of a basic
region may not be a named basic region
but we still can have something like
surface of an ellipsoid we know the
formula for that so we can we can store
this and ellipsoid surface of an ipsec
would be region boundary of ellipsoid
because we don't have a name for it so
here are the 20 properties that we are
storing some of them correspond to
directly to two functions that we have
like region measure others do not like
parametric description or injective
parametric description that's useful for
integrate but it's there is no direct
function for it so we are also storing
some properties of special regions that
that might come useful in computation
wisdom and we store 12 properties of
boundary of the region region operation
so the right now we are storing two
binary operations intersection of
regions so intersection of two special
regions may given special region and
product so Cartesian product
special regions might make it special
regions we can take cartesian product of
a disk quiz with an interval and we'll
get a cylinder for instance and we have
two unary operations image and pre image
which will store the computation of
transform the region and inverse
transform region of a special region
again they may be expressible a special
region currently we have the special
methods for computing linear or linear
fractional transformations of Regents
for higher dimensional unfortunately we
have to go to to the general method and
regional relations right now we don't
have top-level functions but we will
have top-level functions computing
regional relations but we are already
storing subset disjoint an equal
relations we can tell whether to special
regions are disjoint and it will again
it can help in computation with with
with your special regions like if you
have intersection of two regions that
are disjoint when it's empty nothing to
compute or integration over over a union
of 2d joint regions can be we can
integrate separately over each region
okay and we have integration rules so
right now we have specialized
integration rules for 33 basic and
derived region so we we can have code
for fast integration of polynomials so
for many many regions we just have
closed-form formula for what what is the
integral of of a polynomial over over
this region and we have some nice
parameterization stored with with
special region so that integrate has has
an easier job because the general method
with if we go to swing recall the
composition we got parameterization that
uses algebraic functions as integration
bounds which which may not necessarily
be what what integrate can deal the best
ways so for instance for many cases
trigonometric parameterization is much
easier for inter
right to handle and here's some
statistics of implementation so it's
that's that's something what my son was
working on we have 17,000 line of lines
of mathematical code implementing all
all types of properties and special
formulas and we have 1752 different
formulas and special cases so here are
some examples so out of auto
simplification of boolean operations so
in general boolean operations they run
evaluated but if we are working with
special regions like we intersect half
plane with Stadium shape we get a disk
segment here is a picture of it or now I
have to first evaluate something here
this was a picture what happened oh okay
I evaluated out of order I use the same
names everywhere so I have to be
evaluated in correct order so here this
is stadium site intersected with with
half plane and we got this segment and
that's another example which I evaluated
first we intersect cuboid and infinite
plane we get a polygon which is hexagon
I believe here and here's the picture
so this this basically we have four
pairs of special regions we have a rule
that computes the intersection and
here's here are some example using
regional relations Rose for instance we
have here union of disk and polygon and
she turns out to be a polygon because we
can decide that the disk is already
included in the polygon so we can also
simplify this seems trivial but but for
further computation it's really much
easier to deal with with a single
regular polygon instead of a region
Union and here is a lip site and cuboid
and we get back back on the website so
we compute difference of ellipsoid and
cuboid and we got back ellipsoid meaning
that they most probably were this joint
let me yeah they were disjointed we were
able to figure this out and also
simplify region difference so so I set
out of simplification likes further
computation with the region much easier
so here we compute a distance from
region difference of these two regions
which which evaluates to ellipsoid and
and we can use formula for a distance
from ape side in this case and it comes
comes back immediately and this one I
probably shouldn't evaluate so this with
here which wasn't that bad so we first
force it to to use equations
inequalities by by wrapping everything
implicit region and take taking the
region membership formula and now does
the same problem takes four seconds to
solve so it's what well here I have to
let computer 294 times slower
okay so here's out of simplification of
region product so we have product of
disk and interval and it comes back as a
cylinder at the game we can show that it
makes further computation faster we can
integrate a polynomial over over the
cylinder and we have formula for it so
again it takes no time I think this 15
milliseconds is the lowest time this
computer shows for some reason so and if
we use the general method and do the
same integration then okay it was three
seconds or so but but but it's still a
few hundred times store so auto
simplification of a transformed region
so here we have ball it we transform it
using an affine transform and the result
is an ellipsoid and we can compute
volume and again it comes back
immediately because we have formula for
volume of an ellipsoid if we used the
general method instead it would take 10
seconds to compute now distance property
so for instance like let's take the
capsule shape and all those demos so we
have signed distance to this capsule
shape and it works fast enough that I
can actually show it on on the
manipulate demo so what what does it
takes it we need to compute sign region
distance and we have to compute region
nearest to the region boundary so we
have to have the formula involving the
boundary of a region region boundary
does not simplify for a website but we
still have region nearest formula 44
distance to it and this is very fast and
again if if we use the general method
for for signed distance computation we
would it would take 20 seconds for one
point and there I was just using
manipulated so each point was was
computed I mean in fraction of a second
in real time well here here son okay so
yeah for ya 0 seconds and 0 seconds
distance and signed distance for using
the formulas for for especially for one
special point and yeah if we if we
wanted to compute new respond point on
the boundary which was which is the one
that we need to to mark this this point
and be able to to draw a line between
them that that takes forever that that
foot well actually actually it takes a
long time and then fails because because
without in the current version of
Mathematica we cannot even compute
equation in a poetic description of of a
boundary of an arbitrary semi algebraic
set in in r3 in the next version we will
be able to do it so it officially it
won't fail but it will be slower if we
use the general method okay measure
properties so we have 5 the ellipsoid
and we compute measure like zero time
because we have formula and if we if we
use the general method it would take 87
seconds integration over over the rib
side and we have the formula for region
measure of region boundary of ellipsoid
but this formula actually exists only
for up to dimension 3 so for higher
dimensional ellipsoids we there is no
formula for the boundary this already is
users to elliptic functions to get the
three-dimensional website and so this
was you this was using actually with the
slow but it's just
just numerically so we can we can use
numerical integration to compute measure
of a boundary of ellipsoid in higher
dimensions even but it's it's it's still
somewhat slow but it's not not terribly
slow and and we get an answer at least
two numerical approximation of it well
there is no formula so that's the only
way to do it here is some centroid
centroid examples so we have disk
segments again zero time computation of
centroid because we have formula for it
here's what it looks like the disk
segment on the centroid and using
general methods if we compute the same
centroid it takes two seconds and
returns something who really large
because we it's two integrations divided
so that's complicated and the
integration so here we compute integral
over a cone again integral of a
polynomial very calm and it's it's
immediate because we have a formula for
for computing such integrals the general
integration method fails because while
we can get the algebraic
parameterization of the cone integrate
cannot deal with with the algebraic
functions we get there as the
description so it's of this very week we
could do numerical integration using the
general general methods but not exact
integration and here is something that
where we compute an integral of a
polynomial over 5 D simplex again it's
almost immediate there is some
noticeable time 31 milliseconds but the
general integration wouldn't did not
finish overnight so it anticipates
should do it because it's all in your
butt what it takes a long time and here
we compute integral of an a polynomial
over a unit ball in seven dimensions
again fast
and the general method is much slower
which means that it did finish yeah it's
268 seconds so that's that's the first
part of my talk the second part is a
demo of some new features that are
coming in in a future version so we have
to see in the development version and
it's so that the design of what i'm
showing will change but but i'll just
show it what will be possible to do even
if the functions will be named
differently so we have in the new
version we have function for for
computing topological operations on semi
algebraic regions so we can take closure
o magnify ok so we can take closure or
connected component or interior this
this kind of stuff so here is a semi
algebraic set the region's need to call
the composition represents is a semi
algebraic region I don't know if this
particular representation we survive but
but that's what is it now and and here
is the the picture of the region using
semi algebraic region plot I'm using
again this this unofficial function
because it shows what what punk parts of
the boundary are in what parts of the
Panda we are out so so this this
particular region has the blue bank
parts of the boundary are in the gray
parts of the boundary are out so they do
not belong to the set so now i can
compute the closure of the region and
the picture looks like this all the all
parts of the boundary are now blue
and the interior and the interior has
lost the anti-life and next one is
boundary again I would now it says the
dimension is one which is good it should
be one and this here's the picture so
there's the boundary and interior
closure so its closure of the interior
so we should we should lose lose the
antenna but but but we should get us a
closed set they want to evaluate because
takes about 10 seconds to complete the
picture so here's the picture and the
last one is connected components so here
it is it has three components and here
is the picture there are the eyes are
not connected so so here we got this and
one thing I added yesterday so so there
was talk about Gaussian decomposition so
we can we can now compute in one line a
Gaussian the composition of of a 2d
curve so here's here's the curve and so
it's the real part of of this seventh
degree polynomial and here are the
components and he wrote what the picture
looks like so so the idea of the the
composition is that we take take
components of where the polynomial is
positive so these are the blue parts
then we take the boundary of each
component and then we take components of
the boundary so that this part this part
and this part there are three different
curves even though they are the boundary
of the same of the same thing same blue
area so
so when a pic application of this thing
so that was all I had thank you